Vicki is on the line in Florida hi Vicki
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hello
you're gonna speak directly into your
phone I can't hear you okay so I'm in
baby steps too and I have about six
credit card and student loan debt and
I'm currently living at home but paying
my parents right currently have their
retirements pretty fed up they're both
retired and I pretty much you know
brought the up up the idea of help me
get out of the consumer debt is that I
would what do you make a year I made
currently about 42,000 how old are you
I'm I just turned 30 and you live with
your parents yeah they're right retired
and they go in between one property that
they have and then this property yeah
and what do you do for a living
I teach okay and the fifty six thousand
dollars in debt is on what is that about
thirty is thirty six is student loans
but then 20 is about credit cards okay
and you don't have any personal overhead
how long have you been working on this
debt I just started this June pretty
much what were you doing before I was
teaching I just spent the past year
teaching and then I also work at the
summer camp what would have you done
with your income for the last five years
when you were 25 to 30 I was going to
school working part-time working various
jobs oh so you just completed school
recently yeah within the past few years
yeah okay all right oh my god yeah and
so the idea that I flew by them was that
you know they're retired and they they
have their pension set up and they also
they get Railroad Retirement and they
have a
by our a that you know they're not
touching and how much is it I don't know
exactly but in the past they've been
giving us I guess gifts yeah from that
Roth IRA they want to do that and you
want to put it towards your debt fine
but no I would not advance you anything
if I were your parents you're 30 years
old it's time for you to roll up your
sleeves and grow up and pay your bills
if I was your dad that's what I would
tell you I love you but I want you to go
in and have the dignity of winning
instead of me bailing you out you're 30
years old you live with your parents you
just finished your degree go pay your
bills go get your debt paid off
you ain't anything else to do then you
can do that you're very capable of doing
that and I'll be proud of you when you
do